britney spears teases more revelations
to come amid her conservatorship battle
and hints at a break from social media
this is just a groundbreaking day here's
the latest
on monday the pop icon shared two
lengthy messages to instagram
first up this boomerang video featuring
someone standing next to a hashtag free
britney flag
the site inspired britney to write geez
look at that flag
i'm very keen on freedom i love freedom
i love independence
her message then took a serious turn as
brit opened up about her ongoing court
battle
she's currently trying to have father
jamie spears permanently removed as her
conservator
brittany's caption says i know i said
you guys know my situation but let me
clarify
you only know half of it brittany then
addresses her weeks-long instagram spree
speaking directly to quote
a lot of you who say i should be
cautious with what i post
so we really kind of butt heads in that
department britney's message for them
i mean if you really think about it with
what i've been through i believe
i've been way too cautious she added one
day i will live
on the edge one day all that being said
britney's post a few minutes later
seemed to clarify some details about her
new social media strategy
she wrote in a system where i've felt
completely hopeless for so long
at least i do have a platform to share
this was followed by a shout out to one
of her biggest fans
oh yeah oh my goodness britney wrote
selena gomez says it best
the world can be a nasty place i know it
you know it
kill him with kindness this is of course
a reference to selena's 2016 hit song
while britney has been sharing posts
daily to her instagram the headlines
that have followed have seemingly
inspired her to take a step back on
social media
she goes on to say unfortunately the
news has been pretty nasty
saying horrible and mean lies about me
so i'm gonna post a little less from now
on
am i going to take the stage again will
i ever take the stage again
i have no idea oh and by the way this
caption was written next to this
hypnotic tutorial for homemade avocado
toast
brittany ended her message with this was
the coolest thing i've ever seen in my
life
and it's inspired me to take on a new
passion in the cooking field
god bless you beautiful people tata the
post came just after a new blow to
britney's legal fight
earlier monday morning a judge
overseeing the singer's case denied a
request to expedite an upcoming court
date
britney's new attorney matthew rosengart
had called to move up the critical
hearing in court
which has slated to address the removal
or suspension of jamie as her
conservator
less than two weeks ago we pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously to file a petition to
suspend
and remove james p spears in court
documents obtained by et
the motion that rosengart filed last
week read in part
every day that passes is another day of
avoidable harm and prejudice to brittany
and the estate the document went on to
say miss spears should not be forced to
continue to feel traumatized lose sleep
and suffer further
every day matters that court date
remains scheduled for september
29th
you